it's gonna be kevin
glaive left with over a minute but in a
two on four
spray comes through russ gets a kill and
ladies and gentlemen optic gaming
the winners of e-league season two
mixwell was once at the top
of global counter-strike but his time at
the peak
was short-lived we're getting one step
closer mixed well and cousin to try and
save the day
they've spotted one device they'll jump
down his throat and that's gonna be
it it's all done 16-3 now
in 2020 mixwell is back on top and he's
trying to make sure that he stays
there but this time he's not doing it in
cs go
and it's now all on mixwell he's got the
spike and i love this position try and
mix it up a bit
playing out of his own smoke as well but
that will quickly fade it doesn't stay
around for long
he's off the side of it and both players
could be a massive problem here for him
he starts up on the shadow and
comes up clutch once again they cannot
believe it
mixwall is the best valorem player in
europe he might be the best player in
the world
he's the captain of the best squad in
europe g2 esports and he's just waiting
for a chance to prove himself
internationally
but this isn't mix well's first time
being at the very top
of a game like most valent pros mixed
well's esports career began in
counter-strike
peeking into mix well right now looking
more like flick well as he just finds
all these kills so easily continues it
as well this all just
fantastic for him as he's got three make
it four he's hungry for the five is he
gonna get it oh of course he can mix
well
eats them all up as he closes down the
round for optic although he played cs go
since it came out
mixol was a pretty unknown name to most
fans but in 2016
mixwell was thrust into the limelight
and he can get the peak onto hiko here
is it going to be enough though running
back and you're going to step on tonight
as well ridiculous mixed well with an
absurd eighth
optic not out of this yet they've
replaced shazam
with mix well mixed let's hope he mixes
well with the team oh
nice somebody while mixel added some
much needed firepower to the team
optic really didn't take off until taric
joined a few months later
just in front of the old bomb train he
has rushed forward to face off against
[Applause]
with tarik and mixwell as their two
stars optic rose through the ranks of
nacs
quickly becoming one of the region's
best teams and at e-league season 2
they did a lot more than just go
toe-to-toe with the other na squads
is this actually happening caribbean
glaive now the two players were running
connector earlier
one of them is dead mixed well hits the
head shot clean work from him and now
it's glaive
1v4 and he's actually just looking to
get in here see if he can't take a fight
with someone quick and it's not going to
happen tara gets the head shot that is
three kills for mix well in a key round
device takes out one but where's mix
well he's hiding right on the other side
look at this
such a sneaky ninja now he's gonna creep
around with the ak shoot him in the back
and that will be another round here
coming in optic resetting
astralis one more time he just needs
another couple and they will have that
trophy it's going to be kevin
glaive left with over a minute but in a
two on four
spray comes through rush gets a kill and
ladies and gentlemen optic gaming
the winners of e-league season two
in just eight months with optic mix will
experience the success that
few players have ever felt and it was
like living in my own dream that i
already
like went through while sleeping you
know it was like
i was there and i trained myself to be
there
and i and we won i don't know it was a
kind of kind of reaching
what i always wanted at the end of the
year optic were ranked third in the
world by hltv
but just a few weeks later mixwell came
crashing
back down to earth stanislaw must
succeed here otherwise that's gg
down he goes and that's the end of the
round optic are leaving the major
[Music]
rush finally eliminated by pronax great
quad kill coming in from steiner to
clean things up
optic gaming many would have pegged us
by far the favorites here
they said they were slow to start i
don't think they ever started at all
in 2017 optics performance declined and
just a few months into the new year the
roster that made any history
collapsed i don't think it's gonna
happen there's the first frag we could
be saying goodbye to optic indeed we are
there it is renegades managed to
overcome their nemesis and close out the
game
and indeed we do say goodbye to optic
gaming who would have thought
mid 2016 they look lights out winning
one of the biggest titles we have
available in cs go
loser and game leader and now going out
in 0-3
in the major qualifier it's looking
disastrous for this team and i'm sure
this is probably the last time we see
this five-man lineup
yeah i think that goes without saying
one by one players left the roster until
mixwell was the only one left but
he wanted to stay with the org that gave
him his big break
i had many offers to leave and i didn't
want to leave because
optic was the team that gave me the
chance to compete
i never had a salary before them and
they always treated me really well the
fanbase liked me a lot as well
hector was really like a friend of mine
and a mentor
and i didn't just want to leave them
when i really thought we could
build something with them and so optic
signed a new european roster
built around their star spaniard so now
optic will be a full
european lineup we picked up hs from
penta
freiberg x player from nip magisk boy
or magisk and alu x player from phase
but that roster didn't pan out and by
the end of the year
mixwell was out of optic gaming this
business is super super tough sometimes
especially when you become attached to a
player the way that i became
attached to with with oscar mixwell was
adrift
he tried out for g2 for a few months
before going back to spain to play for
movie star riders for a year
he joined cloud 9 in 2019 only for the
roster to blow up a few months later
so in 2020 mixwell took a break from pro
play
and he decided to try out valorant
riot's new tactical shooter
and it didn't take long for people to
notice just how good
he was one heaven i'm watching it
i'm watching it
[Music]
and in june mixville decided to take a
chance by leaving behind cs go and going
to valorent full time
while his retirement from cs go may have
shocked fans
mix actually made up his mind months
before the news came out
i think i decided pretty early but i
didn't want to say it because i wanted
to shock people more
but when i was playing on the beta on
the beat or whatever uh
i liked it a lot like the game was
really fun to me i could play 10 hours a
day
like i used to play cs before and i i
wasn't tired of playing
it and that's the thing that i couldn't
do in cs anymore and
if you have that you can become the best
and alongside his hand-picked roster
mixwell and g2 dominated europe
it's all up to sulcus the soba to keep
things going
first peak not going to be his it will
be g2
your champions here of the we play
valorum invitational
even n a players were starting to take
notice in an interview with the spike gg
n a valor and stud wardell said that he
studies by
watching mixwell play i'm looking at
like mixed well he's pretty good so like
i try to study him a little bit you know
what i'm saying
yeah what is it you're studying for me
in work and you're not just
just like just like things that i can
like pick up from him some things that
he does that like i didn't know
that was like even possible or like you
know what i mean just like expanding my
arsenal
and trying to become better but there
was a bit of an asterisk over g2 success
see unlike nna in europe orgs didn't
flood valerian to sign rosters as the
game came out
but that all changed in august both fun
plus phoenix and team liquid entered
european valor with star-studded rosters
with talent from across the region and
they signed up
just in time for blast twitch
invitational as
usual g2 made the finals sleeping both
nip and fun plus phoenix to get there
but fpx wanted revenge they ran through
the losers bracket to the grand finals
and push g2 to elimination point
nobody's seen no oh there's the reds
they know it's coming they're going to
try and break but they didn't get it
broken in time the health's already back
up
on it how to take a look mix well he
takes them both
shall could come up youtube though first
one goes in for support but it's not
going to work out meadows there to back
him up
and it's now all on mixed well he's
spent all of his knives
on 70 health he's got the spike and i
love this position so i mix it up a bit
oh the paranoia comes out towards him
they try to spray him down he's playing
out of his own smoke as well but that
will quickly fade
he doesn't stay around for long he's off
the side of it and
both players being screwed up could be a
massive problem here for him he starts
up on the shadow and michael
comes off clutch but on the edge of the
feet
g2 showed why they're the true kings of
european valorant
13 11 g2 esports
take the final european ignition series
event
g2's victory was mixwell's coronation
he was the best player on europe's best
team
but he knows all too well just how
fleeting those titles can be
just a few weeks ago team liquid swept
g2 in a best-of-three show match
oh the bulldog will he let it off the
leash mix
well go soaring through the sky it's
actually down to one final player
it's david p it's link it's liquid link
team liquid go undefeated
in the best in the west showdown right
now
mixwell is at the top of the game but he
knows that that's a precarious
place to be thanks for watching if you
want more content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages
you